Turkish heavy weapons aim across the
Syrian border towards the town of Tel a
yard the mainly Kurdish Syrian
democratic forces or SDF defeated ISIL
here in 2015 with the help of us-led
coalition forces the Turkish government
describes the main fighting force in the
SDF as a terrorist organization linked
to its outlawed Kurdistan Workers Party
which is fought against the Turkish
government for decades the SDF control
around 430 kilometers of Syrian
territory along the Turkish border they
have fought and worked alongside US
troops for years they say US president
Donald Trump's decision to withdraw the
nearly 1,000 American soldiers is a stab
in the back a one that gives Turkey an
opportunity to attack that threats made
by Turkey to attack the area is not
something new they have consistently
done it for years
we as Syrian democratic forces take the
matter into account and are fully
prepared to fiercely respond to any
imminent attack on Syrian soil Turkey's
government says it wants to create what
it describes is a safety zone of around
30 kilometers inside Syria so around 2
million of the 3.6 million Syrian
refugees in Turkey can return what
you're looking at there is a Turkish
artillery position now locals tell us
that the army came a couple of weeks ago
to set that position up meanwhile across
the border SDF forces are saying any
military operation by turkey could risk
the global fight against ISIL there are
thousands of ISIL fighters in SDF jails
the US president Donald Trump says
Turkey must bear complete responsibility
for any ISIL fighters that escaped
during a military operation
Turkey has so far offered no clear plan
about how to deal with thousands of
jailed ISIL fighters on the Syrian side
of the border in towns like Televi are
people who have already suffered years
of war are afraid if war erupts people
will be vulnerable and
this place where should we go if you ask
anyone they are saying we are not
leaving but eventually we will be
displaced the prospect of more suffering
for the people of northern Syria is very
real the Turkish army says preparations
for a potential military operation are
complete Charleston averages IRRI on the
turkish-syrian border